le teaser de ce documentaire commence
par une préconisation petit conseil à
l'approché des fêtes
évitez les langoustes des caraïbes dans
son reportage de 52 minutes diffusé
dimanche dernier sur une chaîne
nationale une longue séquence pointe du
doigt la qualité du crustacé en
martinique qui seraient affectés par le
chlordécone à cauet pêcheurs depuis 25
ans la langouste représente 90 % de son
activité en période des fêtes de fin
d'année son chiffre d'affaires est
doublée voire triplée
ce documentaire est pour lui un coup de
massue on entend ça pour nous les
pêcheurs d'autres unités du vauclin
drogba ou deux salles une ou deux
centaines
je pense que et son entourage parce que
nous les pêcheurs ont fait un bon
travail et pour ça on veut pas non plus
qu'on s'a les lots en disant tout et du
n'importe quoi depuis des décennies ako
pêche loin de la zone polluée par le
chlordécone représenté ici en rouge sur
la carte ils s'éloignent environ 30
kilomètres de la zone atlantique
loin des zones contaminées un gage de
garantie selon lui on a acheté un trop
viril pour remonter les casiers et c'est
pour ça on va beaucoup plus loin
on va chercher réellement besoin des
fonds de 80 m qui es tu avec cette
machine n'a hélas on a investi pour ça
moi et il n'est pas question de donner
des podiums produits sains produits
contaminés à la population de la
martinique depuis quelques années la
pratique de la pêche est difficile pour
les professionnels
beaucoup d'entre eux n'hésitent pas à
proposer des excursions en mer pour s'en
sortir financièrement c'est le cas
d'axel lors de ses balades
il propose les langoustes dako à ses
clients même si aujourd'hui la pêche ne
représente que 20% de son activité en
tant que professionnels de la mer et
s'interroge sortir une
quelque chose comme ça par la veille
d'une saison touristique dit ok la
langue ou ce n'est pas bonne et que la
langouste est impacté par le chlordécone
alors que on nous a très bien expliqué
que la langouste pêcher à 25 30
kilomètres du rivage et propre à la
consommation
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne
va pas à l'eau est-ce que c'est pas une
volonté de l'état ou des de la grande
distribution d'anéantir le secteur des
marins pêcheurs enfin moi je me pose des
questions
or de la martinique lors de notre
tournage olivier marie reine le
président du comité régional des pêches
s'est exprimé au téléphone sur le
contenu du documentaire selon lui il
s'agit d'une façon de nuire à la filière
il demande aux consommateurs de faire
confiance aux professionnels
pour rappel la pratique de la pêche en
zone interdite peut être puni d'une
amende pouvant aller jusqu'à 22 1500
euros